تعمل برت اليه
منظور تصاعدي تحت
لا ندخل في جانب سياسيه ولا ندخل في جوانب
التحالفات ولا عندنا
نيه مستقبلا اننا ننتقل لاي نقله نوعيه هي
كانت الا منظور السوق ومنظور الجانب
الاقتصادي
خير الدليل على ذلك
ما قامت به المجموعه في اجتماع اكتوبر 5
اكتوبر
مع كل هذه الضغوط اللي ابتدات
من شهر اغسطس
ودي للمتابعين يراجعون تصريح سويته انا 23
اغسطس
واكد فيه على بعض الاوامر
الاساسيه في عمل الاوبك بلس
واكد في انه المنظومه سوف تستمر في اداء
عملها وفقا
لمنظرها الاقتصادي فقط
وما قامت به وسوف تقوم به في عمليه اعاده
استقال الاسواق اخدم الاعتبار المعطيات
الان
الانيه
وما هو متصور من قبل اوبك بلس
ما حدث في سبتمبر بدايته اكتوبر وكده هو
عمليه
منظورين مختلفين
عليه
الجانب السياسي لحد ما وايضا
الافراد في عمليه
كما سبق في السابق يعني اذكره الجميع كان
في بدايه الازمه الاوكرانيه كان في من
يقول انه روسيا انخفاضه انتاج روسيا سيكون
حوالي ثلاثه مليون ثلاثه مليون
في من يقول في سبتمبر انه الطلب لا هذا
قرار خاطئ
وين احنا الان من هو المخطئ نحن في اوبر
كل هذه الامور
جد تعزز من موثوقيه القرار
اخذتها قبل امس في المقال في الفران
ودي لجميع يطلع عليه شرود
هذا لا يغير في عمليه تركيزنا على الجانب
الاقتصادي وبالتالي اذا اخذنا هذا في
الاعتبار
واخذنا ايضا بكل ما تعرضت للمنظمه
والمجموعه من ضغوط في خلال الربع الاخير
هذا هو مدعات انه ايضا لا يظن بلس انها
ستغير التوجهاتها وطريقه اداءها وعملها
وحرفه المستقبل خلال السنه القادمه على
المحافظه على السوق
ومن جانبه قال ايضا خالد الفالح وزير
الاستثمار السعوديه للاستثمار الاجنبي
المستهدف يمثل اقل من 20 في المئه من
اجمالي الاستثمارات المستهدفه بحلول 20 30
اجنبي في من التريليونين اللي بتتحقق ان
شاء الله في 20 30 مليون
الاستثمار الاجنبي المستهدف اقل من 20% من
اجمالي تكوين راس المال الثاني بمعنى ان
كل دولار او كل ريال نستخدم نحتاج اربعه
دولارات او ريالات من استثمارات الوطنيه
كثير من ما اشارته
وهي بالفعل بعشرات المليارات
هي استثمارات بين اقدام
قطاع الخاص السعودي سواء الشركات وقبل ما
كان
اخي وزميلي
احمد السبيعي يتكلم باسم
شركه النقل البحري معنا ايضا في في الحضور
كثير من اقطاب الاقتصاد السعودي هم
الاطراف اللي توقع غالبا غالبا ان
الاتفاقيات اللي تسمعون عنها هي بين شركات
القطاع الخاص السعودي والاجنبي
اللي تم قبل يومين هنا في الرياض في خلال
القمه الصينيه ما هو
الجزء من سلسله بدات بعد تاسيس وزاره
الاستثمار بل قبلها ايام ثانيه وهو البحث
عن الفرص وتطوير الفرص الاستثماريه هذه
احد المحاور الرئيسيه التي لم تحدث في
السابق في جهه حكوميه ااه
تجمع كل ما لدى
ملاك الفرنسي كانت وزارات حكوميه كانت
هيئات حكوميه كانت شركات القطاع الخاص
وعندهم افكار ونقوم بتطوير هذه الفرص
وبلورتها والقيام ببعض دراسات ما قبل
الجدوى او الجدول مبدئيه في زبده
ووضعها اعلى منصات استثماريه مثل
ما يقوم في مركز التخسيس ايضا في مشاريع
الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص والتخسيس ان احنا
نقوم بعمل موازي بالفرص اللي ما يطلق
عليها جرين فيلد نضعها امام المستثمرين
وبعدين نقوم باتاحه الفرصه
التشارك بين القطاع الخاص السعودي
والاجنبي بس ما تم في الصين تم قبل ذلك في
كوريا قبل اسبوعين خلال الزياره تم في
اليونان تم في فرنسا خلال زياره سيدي
لفرنسا وخلال منتديات ليست مرتبطه بزيارات
قائد الدول او او القياده
وايضا خلال ملتقى الميزانيه اوضح عبد
الرحمن الفضلي وزير البيئه والمياه
والزراعه من المشاريع قيد التنفيذ في
الوزاره حاليا تصل قيمتها الى 90 مليار
ريال مع تنفيذ الوزاره العام الحالي
مشاريع بقيمه 40 مليار
ريال سعودي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مليار ريال سعودي انا تتحدث على الحاجب
الاستخبارات كبيره جدا اليوم احنا عندنا
تقريبا حدود
12 مليون متر مكعب في الشبكات 65
على 20 30
الى 18 مليون متر مكعب المياه سيكون 90%
تقريبا
في 2015 لا يتجاوز ال 5 مليون
5.5 مليون متر مكعب بالمياه اليوم احنا
عندنا
[موسيقى]
9.4 والعام القائد سيزداد الى حدود 11
مليون متر مكعب للبيع اعتقد انجز الكثير
وايضا اعرف انه بقي الكثير لكي يشنجز ولكن
نحن على الطريق الصحيح ان شاء الله
خدمات
المواطنين في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والارتقاء بتلك الخدمات
[موسيقى]